en el último par de vídeos hablamos de
lo que es la línea lización local de una
función y en términos de gráficas
tenemos una bonita interpretación aquí
donde imaginamos una gráfica de una
función y queremos aproximar digamos en
un punto específico podría estar en
cualquier lugar de la gráfica no tiene
por qué estar aquí y necesariamente
podríamos elegirlo en cualquier otro
lado pero si tenemos un punto y queremos
aproximar la función cerca de él
entonces construimos otra función cuya
gráfica sea un plano verdad y
específicamente un plano que sea tan
gente a nuestra gráfica original en ese
punto y esto es digamos visualmente cómo
es que pensamos la línea lización local
verdad y lo que voy a hacer aquí ahora
es hablar de la aproximación cuadrática
muy bien entonces la aproximación
cuadrática esto nos lleva al siguiente
nivel y te voy a mostrar cómo es que se
dé esto gráficamente para que podamos
entenderlos en términos de fórmulas y
gráficamente en lugar de tener un plano
vamos a tener más parámetros y podremos
construir una superficie que más o menos
abraza la gráfica digamos de forma más
precisa verdad va a ser todavía
función más simple en términos de
fórmulas que quizás la función original
pero de hecho va a abrazar a la gráfica
de forma más cercana verdad y a medida
que nos movemos con el punto verdad que
estamos aproximando verdad lo abrazara
de una forma bastante distinta y si
pensamos gráficamente que es lo que es
una aproximación cuadrática básicamente
si rebajamos esta superficie digamos que
se ve fantasmagórica y blanca digamos en
cualquier dirección se parecerá a una
parábola de algún tipo verdad y notemos
que cuando estamos trabajando en
dimensiones múltiples esto hace que las
cosas se vean mucho más complicadas que
en una dimensión por ejemplo si la
rebana moss por aquí en esta dirección
se ve como si fuera una parábola cóncava
hacia arriba pero si lo vemos desde otro
punto de vista verdad entonces se ve
como una parábola cóncava hacia abajo
verdad y entonces lo que obtenemos es
una superficie que de hecho tiene mucha
información acerca de la función
original y cuando vemos cómo es que
abraza a la gráfica vemos que es muy muy
cercana verdad esta aproximación digamos
es mucho mejor que cuando teníamos
simplemente
plano pero por supuesto esto requiere de
algunos pasos más verdad y la
aproximación seguirá siendo muy muy fiel
a la gráfica verdad siempre que estemos
quizás un poquito más lejos que cuando
hablábamos del plano pero siempre que
estemos aún cerca de nuestro punto de
interés verdad eso va a ser algo que nos
da mucha más información para describir
a la gráfica que por ejemplo la línea
lización local verdad nos da de hecho
una mejor aproximación así que en
términos de funciones esto significa que
la parte lineal de nuestra aproximación
verdad como lo vimos en vídeos
anteriores esencialmente consiste en
buscar una función l que depende de xy
de ye verdad y se vea más o menos de
esta forma que sea una constante más
otra constante por x más otra constante
por ye y técnicamente en realidad ésta
no es una función lineal si uno se
quiere poner quisquilloso esto esto no
debería llamarse lineal sino debería ser
una función afín verdad son funciones
afines ok entonces si queremos que
realmente sea lineal
este término constante
no debería aparecer pero en el contexto
de aproximar funciones la gente utiliza
el término lineal para referirse a este
tipo de expresiones verdad entonces
cuando queremos hacer aproximaciones
cuadráticas entonces vamos a considerar
una función q que depende de x y de y
que esencialmente tenga los mismos
términos que teníamos anteriormente a
más bx más ella pero ahora va a tener
los términos con digamos podríamos
pensar que son con exponente cuadrática
verdad aunque aquí por ejemplo en este
término no aparecen exponentes
cuadráticas pero aparecen dos exponentes
uno así que podríamos pensar que es un
exponente cuadra tico verdad más un
último término que es f por ye cuadrada
entonces aquí tenemos d e y f que son
nuevos parámetros y estos términos son
los términos cuadráticas otra vez porque
estamos pensando en todas las
multiplicaciones posibles que hay entre
x
y tendremos parámetros que puedan
controlarlo verdad entonces con esto
podemos ver que tenemos más control
porque antes sólo teníamos tres
parámetros y eso da control de todos los
planos en el espacio y el óptimo digamos
es el que están gente a la gráfica en el
punto que nos interesa y esto puede
variar dependiendo de donde sea y el
punto así que lo que haremos en el
próximo vídeo en el próximo par de
vídeos mejor dicho es hablar de cómo
ajustar las seis constantes para tener
funciones que abracen a la gráfica de
forma precisa y todas dependerán del
punto pues digamos al moverlo la
superficie será distinta esto tendrá que
ver con las derivadas parciales de la
función original y será similar al caso
de la línea lización local sólo que con
más pasos y de eso hablaremos en el
próximo vídeo